in this video i would discuss
the
harmful effects of diabetes
especially
the advanced glycosylation end products
and how these advanced glycosylation end
products could harm our body
so here is a man
and
he had taken a lot of carbohydrate
enriched food in his lunch
so after the lunch his blood glucose
level increased
his blood glucose level increased with
time
and
here we zoom into his intestine so
inside the intestinal lumen there are
lots of glucose
and from the intestine the glucose would
enter the bloodstream so inside the
bloodstream there is huge amount of
glucose after the lunch
now in a ideal person who is not
suffering from diabetes these blood
glucose would enter liver and would be
stored as glycogen but as this person is
suffering from diabetes his insulin
level is low so in type 1 diabetes the
insulin level is low so the glucose
inside the blood vessel could not be
uptaken by the liver cells or the cells
of the muscles
and they cannot be stored in form of
glycogen that is why the blood glucose
level increase
so here the blood glucose level of this
particular person is increased
and when the blood glucose level is
pretty high there could be harmful
effect of these blood glucose
and this we will discuss in a moment so
when the blood glucose level is high
there are a lot of glucose inside the
cell inside the blood vessels
we can see glucose could be attached to
the rbcs and attached to the proteins
serum proteins and they could cause
harmful products so when glucose
encounters the rbc in inside rbc we have
hemoglobin and in the in with the
hemoglobin
these glucose molecules could interact
and
non-enzymatically these glucose
molecules could get attached with
hemoglobin which is called
non-enzymatic glycosylation so here is a
hemoglobin molecule which have four
particular subunits and here is the
n-terminus of the hemoglobin and we are
focusing on the n-terminus valine
residue so with the n-terminus valine
residue what happens glucose molecule
first attach and they first form a shift
base after shift base there is a
rearrangement
in that particular
structure and it forms a glycosylated
version of hemoglobin which is otherwise
known as hp a1c
and this glycosylated version of
hemoglobin is pretty dangerous apart
from glycosylating the hemoglobin
these particular
glucose also
interacts with other proteins
glycosylating them and other molecules
and these products are known as advanced
glycosylated end products
and now we would see
what is the harmful effect of these
advanced glycosylated end product but
before that we should talk a little bit
more about hba1c
so with the increased
glucose level in the
bloodstream or that means
the person have a prolonged
hyperglycemic state so with the
prolonged hyperglycemic state
there is a lot of glycosylation in these
hemoglobins so this hb a1c level in the
blood is also a indirect measure of
its glycemic state of the body
so this hba1c test is a popular test for
diabetic patients
so this test
also tells tell us about
the glycemic state of a person
after that we would learn how this
advanced glycosylation product is
harmful for our body
so these advanced glycosylation product
could cross link with proteins and
form a clump
in with this clump
rbcs
and many other type of blood cells
could get attached
and can lead to formation of a thrombus
now body's defense system
would try to
encounter that and body scavenger cells
macrophages have receptor against these
advanced glycosylation end products
so macrophage would encounter those and
macrophage would secrete eventually tnf
alpha
and interleukin-1
so these tnf alpha and interleukin-1 are
pro-inflammatory cytokine so they would
cause local inflammation
and
for this reason
there is a harm to the body and also
there is a chance of clog formation and
reduced
blood flow
so in this particular uh diagram we have
seen how
advanced glycosylation product could be
harmful
now let's see what are the other
complications of the
diabetes so
first complication could be diabetic uh
cardiopathy or
when this type of advanced glycosylation
product happens in the blood vessels of
the heart then there is a increased
chance of cardiopathy that means enough
uh oxygen is not reaching into the
muscles of the heart and
mainly
there is a
another type of symptom which is called
peripheral artery disease
where the arteries of legs and lower
limbs are mostly affected
and
other symptoms include
diabetic retinopathy and diabetic
retinopathy has a different
have a different cause and it is caused
mainly due to glucose
when glucose level is high cell take up
glucose and inside the cell glucose is
converted inside the vessels of these
particular retina the glucose is
converted
by aldo's reductase into sorbitol and
sorbitol cause osmotic damage to these
blood blood vessels which cause swelling
and leaking out of the fluid
so this is diabetic retinopathy
then
cataract glucoma
can also occur
during diabetes another
important aspect of diabetes is diabetic
foot that means swelling of blood
vessels of the food and
leaking blood from there so it's called
a diabetic food and immense pain in the
food
diabetic retinopathy is another feature
of diabetes
peripheral neuropathy and risk of
stroke is also associated with diabetes
so there are a lot of complication in
diabetes in other set of videos i would
discuss one by one about the
complications of diabetes i hope uh this
video helped you
and if you like my video give it a quick
thumbs up
and please like and subscribe
don't forget share thank you